[Applaudissements]
mais tu l'as déjà vu sur le plateau
d'accord
tu vas devoir que tous les vendredis
pour une chronique people et on va
parler conflit soit haute tension entre
Marion Cotillard et Guillaume Canet mais
ils sont ils sont
ah bah c'est chaud on sait depuis le
début d'année qui sont plus ensemble ça
a depuis janvier février on sait que
leur histoire c'est terminé mais là là
en fait ce qui se passe c'est encore
plus compliqué on parle des enfants
parce que la semaine dernière on a
raconté un peu partout que Marion
Cotillard c'était offert une villa de
ouf à Los Angeles elle a raison bien sûr
bien sûr
tout le monde devrait le faire
[Rires]
la lourdeur
je sais pas s'il est à côté de toi en
tout casprio
c'est closer qui sort ça aujourd'hui
c'est qu'en fait elle veut emmener ses
deux enfants Louise et Marcel avec elle
et les scolarisé dans le bilingue
parce que lui les États-Unis c'est
synonyme du seul film qu'il a fait
là-bas blood tie c'est pour ceux qui
s'en souviennent qui était un four total
il parle pas très bien anglais tous ses
potes sont là ils ont raison
voilà et donc du coup c'est très très
chaud entre eux alors qu'il y a eu un
petit rapprochement cet été ils ont
passé quelques jours ensemble dans leur
villa du Cap Ferret pour les enfants et
pour que ça se passe bien d'ailleurs
j'ai appris avant l'émission que cette
villa bah finalement elle était elle
serait mise en vente à mettre aux
conditionnel mais a priori ils sont en
train de s'en débarrasser justement
[Rires]
je m'en fous
merci merci
carrément non mais là c'est intéressant
pour les enfants alors les salaires des
profs de la Star Ac révélée je connais
la tu as regardé la Star Academy
tu chantes ton un peu non pas du tout
faudrait pas chanter une chanson pour
moi un jour tu ne connais pas les poèmes
tu peux les mettre en chanson
là tu connais aucune chanson
[Rires]
ouais donc c'est public qui nous révèle
ça aujourd'hui c'est c'est les salaires
donc des profs mais aussi du directeur
Michael Goldman qui serait donc à 30000
euros pour les six semaines de Star Ac
on les voit Yanis Marshall successeur de
Kamel Ouali sera à 18000 après ça
descend très très vite c'est pour toute
la famille
6000 euros pour toute
répétitrice etc donc pierre de brouer
par exemple qui
Oscar cisto il est à 3600 avant d'Altaï
à titre de comparaison l'année dernière
elle avait dit qu'elle prenait sur les
dernières stars qu'elle prenait 20000
euros pour l'ensemble de sachant que les
starac durée 12 semaines à l'époque mais
quand même c'est relativement bas mais
je me suis un petit peu renseigné par
exemple avec accès à la roche-joubert
elle avait pris 50000 € pour toute les
saisons de Star Ac comme cachette
directrice parce qu'après elle était
productrice aussi donc il y avait un peu
d'accord ok
selon mes infos en bémol d'aimant ces
chiffres là sans dire si c'est plus ou
moins mais il démente en tout cas pour
eux c'est pas des chiffres alors c'est
qui qui c'est pas du tout parce que tu
sais Benjamin casting vous savez qu'ils
sont faux c'est public c'est public je
vais regarder je vous dirai la semaine
prochaine d'accord la semaine prochaine
je regarde ça je vous dis la semaine
prochaine ah
d'autobiographie explosive du prince
Harry fait trembler le palais je connais
le prince harryjo
William voilà c'est le frère de William
il habite aux États-Unis
[Rires]
complètement alors
c'est l'info qui a fait qui a fait
trembler nos amis anglais parce qu'il a
sorti il a dévoilé le titre la
couverture et la date de sortie de son
bouquin dont on parle depuis longtemps
ce sera le 10 janvier ça va s'appeler
spare ça a quand même coûté 32 euros
donc faut espérer que le lit soit bien
parce que c'est
pas rien et le titre en dit long parce
que en fait ça vient d'une expression
royale je vais jamais réussir à le dire
mais je vais essayer de faire un peu mon
Bertrand Deckers ça vient de Zir and the
spare c'est à dire l'héritier le
remplaçant mais pas de façon très
sympathique c'est plutôt roue de secours
donc il s'autoproclame roue de secours
sur le bouquin on peut imaginer du coup
qui va en profiter pour régler ses
comptes beaucoup avec avec la couronne
peut-être avec son frère est-ce qu'il va
en dire plus sur les accusations de
racisme qu'il avait proféré à l'époque
sur Buckingham est-ce qu'il va dire par
exemple de qui il s'agissait est-ce
qu'il va revenir dans des termes qui
pourraient embarrasser le palais sur la
mort de sa mère c'est possible aussi
parce que selon l'éditeur il va beaucoup
beaucoup parler de cette période de sa
vie donc c'est très très chaud et
d'autant qu'il a dit cette phrase
j'écris ceci comme le prince non comme
le prince que je suis mais comme l'homme
que je suis devenu donc en gros il
s'affranchit encore de tout ça pour pour
balancer un peu donc c'est c'est un
petit peu chaud et dernière petite
anecdote il sort ça le lendemain de
l'anniversaire de Kate Middleton il peut
pas ne pas le savoir donc c'est un petit
peu
tu comprends pour juger je m'en fous
non non
j'ai lâché la honte mais merci merci mon
flow